por primera vez desde que tomó el poder
a principios de esta semana el nuevo
líder de burkina faso habló públicamente
y
comprendo las dudas legítimas causadas
por este bache en el funcionamiento
normal del estado normal
la condición cuando se cumplan las
condiciones según los plazos que nuestro
pueblo habrá definido soberanamente me
comprometo a volver a la normalidad
constitucional sin mangas
y mucho
constitucional normal durante el
discurso transmitido por la televisión
pública de burkina faso
el teniente coronel de amiba habló de su
prioridad número 1 restablecer la
seguridad y se comprometió a reanudar la
lucha contra los terroristas del
autodenominado estado islámico de amiba
también pidió ayuda a la comunidad
internacional
difícil
en este momento particularmente difícil
pido a la comunidad internacional que
apoya a nuestro país para que pueda
salir lo antes posible esta crisis y
reanudar su marcha hacia el desarrollo
[Música]
blackmon pero parte de la comunidad
internacional condenó el golpe el bloque
regional de áfrica occidental cedeao se
reunirá este viernes y podría adoptar
sanciones contra la junta como ya hizo
con malí y guinea tras sus golpes de
estado son determine estamos decididos
en el ámbito de la cedeao a asegurar que
la experiencia de confiscación del poder
por una junta militar en mali es un
fracaso pero también en burkina faso y
en todos y
la toma del poder por parte del ejército
se produce tras años de frustración por
la incapacidad del anterior gobierno
para hacer frente a la violencia del
fundamentalismo islámico sus ataques se
han cobrado más de 2.000 vidas incluidas
las de miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad y han desplazado a millones de
personas en los últimos siete años